hurra hurra das hat doch mit dem rad zu
rad ja hast
was michael haaß mans wo bleibt der
faule geboren ist ja gut dann kurz
duschen
wusstest du eigentlich gesiegt hat sich
untenrum auch gut da habe er danke für
die info alter wir müssen noch zig
fastenzeit ich bekomme überhaupt nicht
mehr nach ja der ist für die gierigen
monopol säcke von der lufthansa die
spinnen
ich habe neulich im flug zum ballern und
40 euro bezahlt da kann ich auch zu
hause bleiben und meine eigene bude voll
kosten
da lob ich mir die deutsche bahn die
setzen in diesen hektischen zeiten
weiter konsequent auf entschleunigung
sogar bei der eröffnung der neuen
superschnellen strecke von münchen nach
berlin
der ic brachte ehrengäste und
journalisten von berlin zurück nach
münchen
er kam erst zwei stunden später an als
geplant
wir deutschen können wird nichts mehr
und wenn stuttgart 21 nicht nur teurer
sondern auch viel später fertig werden
gibt es von uns den goldenen stecken
voll forsten für die deutsche bahn
stuttgart verbunden
darüber ist in kapstadt von du mal
lieber an zu arbeiten aus mücke als den
pfosten für erika steinbach schon fertig
ja gleich gib mir dein handy
ich ruf kurz die zu der frachtabteilung
an sagt mal darf man erika steinbach
hassprediger in nennen die verbitterte
alte schachtel rat danke verbitterte
alte schachtel geht so sehr gut die
verbitterte alte schachtel hat auch
dieses jahr die welt mit ihren tweets
ein bisschen schlechter gemacht wie zb
im mai vielleicht finden sie zeit
wehrmachts fotos von angehörigen
herauszusuchen und zudem den mut sie zum
posten genau oder fotos von opa posten
damals auf wachturm im kz einfach mal
den hut haben
zum glück hatte die neulich ihren
letzten auftritt im bundestag nach 27
jahren im deutschen bundestag ist das
heute meine letzte rede
es waren zehn jahren
dafür mit der vollkosten für ihr
lebenswerk die goldene giftspritze
nico verdient an erika steinbach moment
was ist denn mit v coupé krieg den iks
das war doch der wahl bis 2017 ist für
die afg antreten und dann kommt den
arsch im bundestag tritt sie wieder auf
genau das hat sie doch dem locker damals
vorgeworfen haben sie gesagt nicht gehe
davon aus oder nicht davon aus dass bei
und luca und diejenigen die ihm folgen
die größe besitzen ihre mit der afg
errungenen mandate zurück zu geben
das datum das damals sozusagen ja gruppe
als ist auch drogen und noch dünner als
wir fahren dann eine neue partei
gegründet namens die blauen
dafür gibt es an diesem post die blauen
den namen hatte sich ursprünglich seiner
brüder schützen lassen
schlumpfine was hab ich ging damals
gespürt was hast du fix es war schön die
werkstatt durch und ich baue so lange
den vollkosten für boris becker fertig
wobei der wird am ende eingeblendet war
nun mal jetzt meine pfeile altersklassen
schreiber ich mache mich unsichtbar
das möge so einfach besser keine angst
kinder der us mutter hat nur eine
fleischwunde